hey michael
recently someone told me that they think
romance novels movies etc are as bad to
women as porn is to men while these two
are not on the same level for obvious
reasons it did make me think about the
tick tock trend talking about the appeal
of men written by women
do you think growing up watching movies
like pride and prejudice and the titanic
gives women unrealistic hopes
that is do i need to leave the romance
to fiction and just settle down with
someone practical
no i don't think so i i think
we live in a culture right now where men
have been particularly degraded by the
educational system by the culture by the
licentiousness throughout the society
that's now tolerated by the government
and and by women who are willing to uh
give them the milk for free and so they
have no
particular incentive uh at least at the
material level to uh to go by the cow so
i don't think it's wrong for women to
aim for something higher than just some
loaf couch potato idiot man who has no
ambition and just eats potato chips all
day
i think you can aim higher but but the
one thing i would recommend is
maybe you want your mr darcy to use your
pride and prejudice reference you want a
man like mr darcy
but
don't make an idol out of mr darcy i'm
actually going to take it out of the
realm of romance for a second and put it
into the realm of your career this might
be a little easier to understand people
have
heroes
people
when they think about their life and
their career they say i want to be like
ronald reagan
i want to be like i don't know elon musk
i want to be like donald trump i want to
be
and that's good it's good to have those
goals in mind and to say okay he did
this so maybe i should do something like
this or this that or the other thing
but you can't just replicate someone
else's career you're not just gonna be
ronald reagan and do all the things
ronald reagan did or you're not just
gonna do all the things elon musk did
you're not just going to you're not
going to get exactly mr darcy
okay
it's good to have the
these virtues in mind and these good
habits in mind and these good attributes
in mind
but
when you make an idol out of them then
you really are living in a fantasy and
then you really will be disappointed 40
years ago ronald reagan saw massive
inflation unlike anything the country
had ever seen before
until today in reagan's own words
inflation is as violent as a mugger as
frightening as an armed robber and as
deadly as a hitman well i can't tell
that was either ronald reagan or jon
voight i'm not sure which voice that was
right now your retirement accounts are
under attack thanks to the inflationary
policies of this administration if you
have not yet called birch gold the only
people that i trust to help you
diversify your 401ks and iras into gold
then you are missing the boat actually
you're treading water without a life
vest birch gold has your life vest let
them help you convert an ira or 401k
into a tax sheltered ira in gold with
thousands of satisfied customers and an
a plus rating with the better business
bureau you can trust birch gold to
protect your savings
right now text knowles k-n-o-w-l-e
to 98 98 98 to get a free info kit on
gold reagan knew the biggest threat to
your wealth protect yours now text
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s to 9 8 9 8 9 8 to
get your free info kit now
did you like that clip i'm glad ring the
bell please that way you'll get
notifications and then because sometimes
you don't get notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we will see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]